what is happening reject nation I'm Greg
Alba and I'm John we gonna watch today
super easy barely inconvenience Ryan
from Screen Rant pitch meeting x-men
first class we got introduced to this
friend's pitch meeting about a month ago
I've been binge-watching the [ __ ] out of
these pitch we've seen so many since
then haven't yet seen this because today
is a top patron we worked here whatever
video you requested must definitely put
up on YouTube made sure to avoid this
because I wanted to do a reaction with
it this Gregory bollocks request
oh you saw this guy I saw this guy not
two hours ago really a sidewalk in
Toluca Lake Cal that's so cool
yeah that's so cool with another guy I'm
addicted to pitch meetings man yeah
they're just like another form of review
and the funniest format you could
possibly ask yeah little bit of
Hollywood ribbing to go with oh yeah no
it's great yes sir I do this one's gonna
take place in the past oh so is this
like a prequel or a reboot yes well okay
the Nazi concentration camp and this bad
guy Shaw is gonna kill Magneto's mom
well that's not very nice alone it's not
so then Magneto's powers dead Unleashed
and he just destroys everything
he kills guards he shoots metal
everywhere sounds exciting
yeah so this guy shot it's like oh okay
good to know your powers are unlocked by
pain and anger wait magneto didn't do
anything to
guy that actually killed his mom nothing
at all because we still need him for the
rest of them she break in there because
she's scared in Hungary so she wants to
look in the fridge she's a hungry child
so she breaks into a mansion and races
the fridge that's what we're going with
huh then we're gonna jump forward like
20 years and Rona Magneto's gonna be on
the hunt for shock as he wants revenge
wait what happened in those 20 years
unclear how did he escape from shock I
don't know what is it just now on the
path to revenge yes this is what the
story starts well okay so anyway baby no
tracks down some former Nazis in a bar
because they'll know where she is okay
and then he kills them but he gets
information from them first no he just
kills them oh it's gonna be tough room
to find shop you just killed the guys
who know where he is actually it's gonna
be super easy really okay so he knows
that Shaw's on a boat in Miami and
there's no need to question them at all
but that picture could have been taken
at any point in time this is on boat he
could be anywhere in the world by now
well that's a good point but it turns
out he is still on a boat in Miami so it
all works out oh what's going on with
him now well it turns out shot could
absorb energy and reuse it and he also
has a couple of other bad guys on his
group oh yeah well there's Emma Frost
who's a telepath and get turned into
diamonds there's Nightcrawler but red
and there's a guy what's Shawn's playing
here well he wants to trick the USA and
Russia into starting a nuclear war so
all the humans can die and the mutants
can survive if he has a telepath and a
teleporter can he just get into the
specific room he needs to to fire the
missiles himself probably but you're
gonna go with this complicated plan
instead how come so the x-men can stop
up fair enough anyway super fast this is
gonna end up going to talk to the
government and he's gonna do this cool
thing where he just freezes everybody
just so we can talk to one person oh he
can freeze everybody that's gonna be
useful moving forward yeah you think so
so then he
needlework on a little recruitment
mission and make it to commute so that's
fun and we're gonna find out how they
all got their nicknames how does that
happen they just they gave them to each
other okay yeah that's pretty
straightforward
anyways any place where they're all
hanging out why does he do that when he
goes to see them like hey you guys want
to join me and most of them were like no
so he's like okay nevermind why doesn't
he kill me well he does kill one of them
but only because he tried to attack it
well who does he kill this dude named
Darwin and he is the power to adapted
anything to survive so how does shot
Gila with like a ball of energy and how
come he's not able to adapt to that
because fair enough this McCoy that
really wants to find a cure to some of
the weird physical stuff that comes with
being a mutant oh right because he's
blue and hairy right yet actually he
just has some weird feet when he wants a
way to hide them what about you know
shoes Oh
ignoring the existence of shoes is tight
you can't see my toes right now sure I
can anyway so Hank ends up making this
serum using Mystique's blood but right
before the big final fight he tries it
and that turned some blue and hairy why
would he test something like that right
before going to save the world either to
look good for the big fight I guess
pretty weird priorities that's pretty
cool she's gonna show the guards that
she can easily escape well why doesn't
she I don't know well okay and then
later shots can absorb the energy from a
nuclear core oh I bet he's gonna do
something cool with that nope oh where
the Angermann have to deal with the
Cuban Missile Crisis or something no we
are yeah there's gonna be a ship full of
Americans and a ship full of Russians
and the x-men have to stop them all from
starting a war well good thing professor
X has the ability to freeze large groups
of people as established earlier of the
movie yeah well he's not gonna do
why not focus by the time I got to
writing this scene I forgot that I
established that power so he's not gonna
use it fair enough and so that he's
gonna get hit by a lectin bullet in the
spine and that's how we loses control of
his legs didn't have bulletproof suits
or anything actually we're gonna make a
point of having Hank make bulletproof
suits and Professor X is the one that
points out that they're bulletproof
Vegas Hank is just really bad at making
stuff I guess so so then it's Professor
X is lying there paralyzed Magneto's
gonna be like all right who wants to
join my team let's go not really the
time for that Nightcrawler is gonna
teleport them away so how did the other
mutant sleeves unclear sir aren't the
American and Russian forces still right
there they are a little risky to go back
in time like this we might make some
mistakes that mess up the timeline don't
worry about that sir I got it under
control all right if you're sure 100% 15
unexplained hey guys it's Ryan here hope
you enjoyed that pitch meeting we have a
ton of these on the channel to check out
you'd also leave me a comment like I
make the effort in the outro to just
come across as sincere as possible not a
me at all
yeah spent the last five and a half
minutes being hammies yeah make sure
that people don't think this is just you
know how I ain't I don't want people to
think I talked this way in some ways I
feel like this segment could be called
plot holes yeah because of how they
poked fun of how he pokes fun at how
like jokes are just like you know super
easy barely an inconvenience just cuz
yeah there's a couple of like
reoccurring jokes that he uses for all
of his segments and I love that just
cause yeah it's like what a plot needs
to yeah what if all these things that we
noticed actually came up in the meeting
yeah and yeah just the way he's able to
sell that attitude I'm just like
completely unconcerned about any
possible problem yeah yeah exactly
barely thank you yeah
whatever and with these kinds of movies
especially to like in the superhero
realm like there are so many instances
of like why didn't that power come back
why didn't this ability that would be
super handy yeah like the main part of
the movie it's kind of telling so my
biggest takeaways especially with the
bigger superhero movies that he covers
it's always like well wouldn't it be
easier if they just did this wouldn't it
be easier if they just did this this is
like a little bit different from
something like cinemasins which is like
breaking down everything or nitpicking
yeah here he's really just he tends to
focus on just the main things the main
plot points that are like major plot
holes yeah and like the main actions
that are gonna get us from place to
place yeah yeah it's kind of like an
outline of the movie with some major
plot holes highlighted you know for
humorous purposes when like going off
that comparison I think this show has
kind of a fun tone of voice because it
is like poking holes and things about
these movies it's identifying plot holes
and little mistakes or oversights but
not in a way that feels like malicious
or like he's getting a kick out of just
like tearing this movie apart like it
seems like it's all in good fun
especially in the way that the two
characters are played because you could
easily skewer the exact character
specifically and it is kind of biting
but I just love the kind of tone that he
strikes with both of those characters
because they're both just so happy
go-lucky
yeah well they both have this approach
of like let's just make money yeah yeah
and and just the little motifs that keep
coming back like every time he's like
tight tight you know this thing is cool
before the beginning of this video it's
just that is that is a question that
I've only seen an x-men first class a
couple of times but every time I've seen
it I go why did he just kill Kevin Bacon
at the very beginning yeah why does he
kill everyone else in that room well he
doesn't kill Kevin Bacon and it's true a
lot of the time in these big Hollywood
movies a lot of these things move
forward just cuz a lot of things before
word because they have to and I like
about his character approach as well
with with these two I like when he takes
the time for them to question the
choices that they make like when the
writer questions the producer or when
the producer questions the writer but
then they just agree to it anyway yeah
yeah yeah
they can't resolve this there's like
okay that's gonna be a problem
okay whatever rules hopefully people
don't notice it you know yeah well
because I feel like that's kind of what
we're all left to wonder about when we
read all this movie news and we see
certain things happen in movies is like
it really is kind of a perfect portrayal
of the conversation that plays out in
your own head when you're like I wonder
what being a fly on the wall would have
been like when this movie got green well
thanks for requesting that Gregory
Bullock this guy is something special
you know I rarely find another YouTube
channel nationally at this point in the
game where I'm like wow I'm just I'm
binge watching the [ __ ] out of this
random guy Downey and Gregory Bullock my
friend you are one talented talented guy
him and I have been having a lot of
these like really deep conversations
back and forth the way he is with his
vocabulary and making such powerful
poignant points about society about
culture it makes me wish that he could
put a lot of these words out there in
his own fashion that I always talking
about starting up a channel and let's
talk about movies and everything but I
feel like you can be something so much
deeper than that man like yeah there are
times you write stuff to me we're all
just screenshot it and be like that's
how I'll start phrasing things from now
on or you have kind of altered my point
of view on something from how you have
opened my mind in this new direction
Gregory you're a deep artistic guy and I
hope you keep at it man I hope you start
to create more art put it out there in
the world the world needs more people
like you you have velvety pipes and a
calming disposition and now I'm gonna
start going through y'all's messages and
just eavesdrop you know really is it
poignant at least like an insult that
I'll read and be like well that hurts
but it's undeniably beautifully phrased
feelings getting hurt
tight tight you guys can subscribe to
Screen Rant subscribe to the reject
nation click that notification bell and
we'll catch you on the flippety-flip